there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves M Cosmetics re-released
its color drop serum blush with a new
and improved formula and packaging the
old packaging was notoriously difficult
to use it had this dropper thing that
just would not dispense properly this
new dropper is so much better you do
have to build this blush up but it gives
you a really pretty dewy flush of color
I honestly can't see a difference
between the old formula and the new one
this new one is just easier to use I'm
not super into this kind of blush
formula I prefer the Brand's powder or
cream blush over this but it's pretty
and it didn't break up my Foundation
I've been dying to test out the new
house Labs Foundation I've heard nothing
but amazing things and I was not
disappointed I went in with my
foundation brush first and this just
totally Blends into the skin seamlessly
the coverage is on the lighter side so I
added a little more and I am really
impressed by how weightless it is it has
skin care ingredients in it and it
actually feels like like skin care it
feels like you have absolutely nothing
on your face all of my other products
Blended on top of this beautifully so
this Foundation is a 10 out of 10 for me
I also got the bio blurring loose
setting powder and I love this too it
definitely does blur the skin and sets
your makeup without making it look dry
or cakey it's so soft and finely milled
and it's also talc free which is great I
tried a couple lip products from Fenty
Beauty the gloss bomb heat Universal lip
luminizer and plumper in hot chocolate
Heat and the gloss bomb ice cooling lip
luminizer in cold-hearted let's talk
about this new gloss bomb ice first it
looks like a pale blue color but it goes
on totally clear it has a really nice
minty scent you get that cooling effect
instantly and I like it it also feels
great on the lips like the other Fenty
glosses just super hydrating and shiny
the gloss bomb heat is not a new formula
but people have been loving the hot
chocolate heat shade it's like a brown
with a hint of rosiness to it because
it's on the more sheer side this color
looks incredible on so many different
skin tones and it actually does plump
the lips really nicely it's not an
uncomfortable Plumping effect at all a
few of you asked if I could review Moon
cap polishes so I have a few to talk
about this first one is called
Illusionist and it's a magnetic
multi-chrome I feel like mooncat always
has these really interesting colors like
this that I don't see very often the
magnetic effect on this one is so cool I
couldn't stop staring at my nails this
neck shade is called cyclone and it's a
blue jelly flaky polish the way these
iridescent flakes look in this jelly
really give you this ocean Vibe so I
loved this one too the last polish I
tried was emo for life which is just a
plain black creme polish I honestly feel
like this one impressed me the most
because it was literally Pitch Black in
one coat the pigment on it is incredible
and the formula is so smooth the prices
do vary depending on the formula but
overall the quality of the Polish is
really good and I also love the brush
and handle on these bottles they make it
super easy to paint my nails this is the
Charlotte Tilbury take it all off it's a
bi phase makeup remover and I had to
Google what that meant because I had no
idea it basically means you get an oil
and water in one and you have to shake
the product to combine it it
specifically says this is for eyes
lashes and lips you have to shake it
apply it to a cotton pad and soak the
area for a few seconds for an easy
removal this honestly worked really well
and I tried it on waterproof mascara
which always takes me forever to remove
I also have very sensitive eyes and this
didn't irritate them at all I liked this
but I think it's a little too pricey for
a makeup remover you're only supposed to
use on your eyes and lips say just
dropped these lip lures they're matte
lipsticks that you can build up to be
super full coverage or dab on for a soft
blurred lip I use the shade modern first
and just stabbed it on with my finger it
gave this really pretty soft wash of
color this other one in the shade
classic really shocked me because it's
so smooth and pigmented I was laughing
because I definitely went too far over
my lip line but we move I would
recommend a lip liner with these because
the formula isn't as matte as you'd
expect and it does move around a little
overall I think these are nice and feel
good on the lips
[Music]